expect to see something different
something scary something fun and
something heartfelt
werewolf by night is a story where a
bunch of characters are coming together
were a very frightening time we're going
to introduce you to Jack and Elsa and
see what dangerous Adventures they get
up to over one night trapped with a
secret cabal of Monster Hunters it's
kind
of first real full exploration into this
super natural Universe Disney plus we
have the opportunity to tell stories of
different levels and so this is our
first special presentation it's a little
bit under an hour because it's giving
you a taste maybe an appetizer of the
monster side of the MCU we went and we
filmed it completely in black and white
and I think that's going to be a
different experience for everyone it is
a throwback to the 30s and 40s horror
movies that I loved whenever I was
growing up it's really unique what we
want to do is create an experience for
somebody that years from now they can go
you know what scared me as a kid this
when I watched this and I never forgot
it I hope that they maybe might go back
and explore some of those old horror
movies as well some of those ones that I
loved whenever I was a kid I hope that
the audiences get to enjoy the fun the
scares the excitement but also fall in
love with these characters of Jack and
Elsa and see where they go on their
journey and maybe what surprising end
they come to if I would have to turn
into an animal under a full moon
it would be
some cross between probably an ape and a
wolf I guess I think I'd be a bat a bat
they're a little scary they're also a
little cute werewolf by night is scary
vintage horror with a heart a love
letter to every movie I grew up watching
as a kid werewolf by night is the tale
you've been waiting for to bring you
into the monster side of the MCU don't
miss werewolf By Night live streaming on
Disney Plus
[Music]